more than two weeks after political
protests began in Cairo's liberation
square crowds continued to arrive
located adjacent to the square Kairos
Egyptian Museum is at the epicenter of
the action during one chaotic early day
of the demonstrations in late January
looters entered the museum and damaged
priceless antiquities but restoration
work got underway quickly on the objects
damaged most of them are good in good
shape and in a little bit need
restoration about 25 3 pieces museum
director Tareq LED shows objects that
were in a case that was damaged many are
fine but a few are in need of
restoration this is not the damaged it
was dismantled as you see here we have a
part broken one case was damaged in a
collection of King Tut the thieves found
only wooden statues and discarded them
the famous golden mask was safely under
lock and key from one glass window the
thief made his way inside the museum but
because it was completely dark he
couldn't see any of the museum
collection so that's why we have the
minor damage happened to the collections
but we have all the masterpieces of the
egyptian museum all the collections
almost safe
dr. Tareq says the intruder was
eventually apprehended near the statue
of Sekhmet the goddess of protection
officials are downplaying the incident
and they're quick to show that most of
the museum remains unharmed protected by
the Egyptian army museums all over Egypt
are safe
Saqqara develop the kings all the
selling dogs all the coptic monastery
the egyptian what the muslim are they
the Islamic monuments and veronik and a
Greek Roman are completely safe if carry
Museum and the pyramids are safe Egypt
we'll be safe
you